witaj ponownie w kursie „Zrozumieć informację i obliczenia kwantowe". Nazywam się John Watrous i jestem
dyrektorem technicznym ds. edukacji w IBM Quantum. To jest ósma lekcja tej serii i ostatnia lekcja w
drugiej jednostce serii, która dotyczy algorytmów kwantowych. Omówiliśmy model zapytań obliczeń, w tym kwantowe
algorytmy oferujące udowodnione przewagi nad klasycznymi algorytmami w ramach tego modelu. Omówiliśmy podstawowe pojęcia związane z
algorytmami kwantowymi i sposobami mierzenia kosztu obliczeniowego, a w poprzedniej lekcji omówiliśmy estymację fazy i algorytm Shora.
W tej lekcji omówimy algorytm Grovera, który zapewnia kwadratową przewagę kwantową nad
klasycznymi algorytmami dla tak zwanych nieustrukturyzowanych problemów wyszukiwania, które opiszę, gdy przejdziemy do
lekcji. To wszystko są podstawowe tematy dotyczące algorytmów kwantowych. Istnieją także inne kwantowe
algorytmy, jak również ogólne paradygmaty łączące różne algorytmy kwantowe i techniki algorytmiczne kwantowe, i
jeśli jesteś zainteresowany, zachęcam do sprawdzenia Quantum Algorithm Zoo, który kategoryzuje znane algorytmy kwantowe i zawiera wiele odniesień
do oryginalnych artykułów badawczych, które przyczyniły się do ich rozwoju. Jednak w tej serii
skupimy się tylko na podstawach i zaczynając od następnej lekcji przejdziemy do nowego tematu, ale
najpierw porozmawiajmy o algorytmie Grovera. Oto przegląd lekcji. Zaczniemy od krótkiej dyskusji
na temat problemu obliczeniowego, którym będziemy się zajmować, czyli nieustrukturyzowanego wyszukiwania. Intuicyjnie mówiąc, możesz
myśleć o problemie nieustrukturyzowanego wyszukiwania jako przeszukiwaniu zbioru elementów, który nie jest posortowany i nie został uporządkowany w użyteczny
sposób. Następnie omówimy algorytm Grovera, który jest algorytmem kwantowym oferującym kwadratową przewagę nad
klasycznymi algorytmami, i wkrótce dokładnie wyjaśnimy, co to oznacza. Bardzo ogólny opis
działania tego algorytmu jest taki, że najpierw następuje krok inicjalizacji, a następnie operacja, którą będę nazywał
operacją Grovera, jest iterowana pewną liczbę razy, a na końcu następuje pomiar, który ujawnia kandydata
na rozwiązanie problemu wyszukiwania. Wyjaśnię, czym jest operacja Grovera i jak może być
zaimplementowana na komputerze kwantowym, a następnie przeprowadzimy analizę tej operacji, żeby lepiej zrozumieć, co robi i dlaczego jest przydatna do
wyszukiwania. Trzecia część lekcji dotyczy liczby iteracji
w algorytmie Grovera, czyli innymi słowy liczby razy, ile powinna być zastosowana operacja Grovera, zakładając, że chcemy
zmaksymalizować prawdopodobieństwo, że algorytm z powodzeniem znajdzie to, czego szukamy, minimalizując jednocześnie jego
koszt. Zaczniemy od unikalnego problemu wyszukiwania, który jest szczególnym przypadkiem, w którym istnieje dokładnie jedno rozwiązanie
naszego problemu wyszukiwania, a następnie rozważymy, co się dzieje, gdy istnieje wiele rozwiązań. Na koniec
zakończę lekcję kilkoma krótkimi uwagami o algorytmie Grovera i jego uogólnieniach. Zacznijmy od
problemu obliczeniowego, którym będziemy się zajmować przez całą lekcję. Najpierw, jak to często robimy,
niech Sigma oznacza alfabet binarny i będziemy używać tej notacji przez całą lekcję, więc nie będę
ciągle ci o tym przypominał. Załóżmy, że mamy funkcję f, która odwzorowuje binarne ciągi znaków o pewnej długości n na
alfabet binarny. Nasze założenie jest takie, że możemy łatwo obliczyć tę funkcję,
na przykład być może mamy Boolean circuit dla tej funkcji, którego rozmiar jest wielomianowy w n. Nie oznacza to jednak, że jest to
koniecznie prosta funkcja w jakimkolwiek sensie ani że mamy szczególnie dobre zrozumienie tej funkcji. Na przykład być może mamy
dość skomplikowany i zawiły Boolean circuit dla obliczania f, który pozwala nam go obliczać dla różnych ciągów wejściowych, ale niekoniecznie ma
ładną postać zaprojektowaną, żeby ułatwić nam życie. Naszym celem jest znalezienie rozwiązania,
przez co rozumiemy binarny ciąg znaków o długości n, który powoduje, że f przyjmuje wartość jeden. Ogólnie rzecz biorąc, jest to bardzo trudny
problem obliczeniowy lub przynajmniej podejrzewamy, że jest bardzo trudny. W szczególności, jeśli wejście jest opisem
Boolean circuit dla obliczania funkcji f, to jest to tak zwany problem NP-zupełny. Jednym ze sposobów
sformalizowania tego problemu jest ujęcie go jako problemu zapytań i rzeczywiście, na potrzeby tej lekcji, rozsądne jest
myślenie o tym problemie wyłącznie w kontekście modelu zapytań. Ale kiedy myślimy o tym, gdzie lub kiedy ten
problem może pojawić się w praktyce, bardziej naturalne jest myślenie o f jako obliczanym przez Boolean
circuit. Jak widzieliśmy w lekcji szóstej, możemy jednak połączyć te dwa punkty widzenia poprzez konstrukcję, przez którą przeszliśmy, biorąc Boolean circuit i
konwertując go na quantum circuit dla implementacji operacji zapytania lub gate zapytania. W każdym razie, konceptualnie mówiąc,
wejściem do problemu jest ta funkcja f i szukamy rozwiązania, jeśli istnieje, a jeśli
nie istnieje rozwiązanie, co oznacza, że f okazuje się stałą funkcją zerową, to prawidłowym wyjściem jest raport
że nie ma rozwiązań. To jest nieustrukturyzowany problem wyszukiwania w tym sensie, że nie ma
nic szczególnego w f, co ułatwiałoby znalezienie rozwiązania. Nie jest tak, że przeszukujemy
dane, które zostały już uporządkowane lub załadowane do struktury danych jakiegoś rodzaju, która ułatwia wyszukiwanie, i nie ma obietnicy dotyczącej
funkcji f, która mogłaby nam pomóc. Jednym ze sposobów myślenia o tym jest to, że jest to jak szukanie konkretnego
numeru telefonu w książce telefonicznej, w przeciwieństwie do szukania imienia, co jest znacznie łatwiejsze, zakładając, że imiona zostały
ułożone alfabetycznie. W praktycznych terminach nie chodzi tak naprawdę o przeszukiwanie danych,
które zazwyczaj organizujemy i przechowujemy w sposób ułatwiający wyszukiwanie. Jest to bardziej reprezentatywne dla szukania
rozwiązania skomplikowanego równania, na przykład, lub może szukania kombinacji otwierającej
zamek. Na marginesie, sensowne jest myślenie o tym problemie w kontekście modelu zapytań, niezależnie od tego, jak możemy
czuć do praktycznej trafności tego modelu. Oczywiście w prawdziwym życiu nie ma wyroczni ani czarnych skrzynek, ale dopóki
nie dowiemy się inaczej, skomplikowane i tajemnicze Boolean circuits są trochę jak czarne
skrzynki. Teraz pomyślmy o algorytmach rozwiązywania tego nieustrukturyzowanego problemu wyszukiwania i będziemy to robić
w modelu zapytań dla uproszczenia. Jeśli mamy Boolean circuit dla naszej funkcji zamiast czarnej skrzynki,
możemy nadal uruchamiać algorytmy zapytań, ale oczywiście nie możemy wykluczyć możliwości, że zostanie odkryty nowy algorytm
dla tego problemu, który nie opiera się na zapytaniach, ale nie będziemy się tym zajmować.
Najpierw trochę notacji. Całkowita liczba ciągów wejściowych do funkcji f wynosi 2 do
WEBVTT
małego n, gdzie małe n jest długością ciągów wejściowych do f, a od tej chwili niech duże N oznacza tę liczbę 2 do
małego n. Dość powszechne jest używanie dużej litery w ten sposób do oznaczania dwójki podniesionej do potęgi małej
wersji tej litery. Będziemy dużo mówić o liczbie N, więc to po prostu będzie
wygodne i pomoże utrzymać pewien porządek. I ponownie, ta notacja obowiązuje przez
całą lekcję. Oczywiście możemy klasycznie rozwiązać problem wyszukiwania, po prostu
iterując przez wszystkie możliwe n-bitowe ciągi w dowolnej wybranej kolejności i obliczając f dla każdego z nich.
Jeśli w dowolnym momencie znajdziemy rozwiązanie, możemy się zatrzymać, ale w najgorszym przypadku skończymy na obliczaniu f dla każdego pojedynczego
ciągu wejściowego, więc wymaga to N, czyli dużego N,
zapytań. Moglibyśmy zdecydować się mierzyć koszt tego obliczenia w inny sposób, nie tylko w liczbie zapytań, ale liczba zapytań
reprezentuje liczbę razy, kiedy musimy obliczyć funkcję f, i rozsądne jest oczekiwanie, że obliczenia f będą dominować koszt
tego obliczenia. To jest w rzeczywistości najlepsze, co możemy zrobić z algorytmem deterministycznym
i ponownie jest to w kontekście modelu zapytań. Jeśli zapytaliśmy każdy ciąg wejściowy
oprócz jednego i f przyjęło wartość zero dla wszystkich z nich do tej pory, skąd możemy być pewni, że ostatni
ciąg nie jest rozwiązaniem? I odpowiedź jest taka, że nie możemy, więc potrzebujemy wszystkich N zapytań w najgorszym
przypadku. Moglibyśmy również użyć losowości, która może oferować pewne nieznaczne ulepszenia, takie jak zmniejszenie
oczekiwanej liczby zapytań potrzebnych do znalezienia rozwiązania, gdy ono istnieje, lub moglibyśmy efektywnie handlować poprawnością
za zmniejszenie liczby zapytań, ale jednak, jak byś to nie kroił, nadal będziemy potrzebować liczby zapytań liniowej
w N. Klasycznie mówiąc, potrzebujemy liniowej liczby zapytań, co oznacza liniową
w dużym N. Algorytm Grovera jest kwantowym algorytmem wyszukiwania, który radzi sobie lepiej. Wymaga tylko O
pierwiastka z N zapytań. Te zapytania wykonywane są w superpozycji, więc to nie jest magia, ale
jest to znacząca poprawa w stosunku do tego, co jest możliwe klasycznie i to właśnie oznacza kwadratowa
przewaga. Czy ta kwadratowa przewaga kwantowa nad klasyczną może być przekształcona w rzeczywistą przewagę w praktycznym
sensie? Prawdopodobnie nie w najbliższym czasie, ale w odległej przyszłości, kto wie. Ale nawet jeśli
algorytm Grovera nigdy nie doprowadzi do praktycznej przewagi w wyszukiwaniu, jest mimo wszystko ważną częścią
fundamentów algorytmów kwantowych, którą warto zrozumieć. Zanim przejdziemy do samego algorytmu Grovera, musimy
krótko omówić tak zwane phase query gates. Wiele algorytmów kwantowych w modelu zapytań jest naturalnie wyrażonych
za pomocą phase query gates i zobaczymy, że algorytm Grovera jest konkretnym
przykładem. Zacznijmy od krótkiego przeglądu zwykłych query gates dla funkcji f
postaci, o której mówiliśmy. Gate zapytania UF jest zdefiniowany na standardowych stanach bazowych, jak pokazano na
ekranie, a dla superpozycji standardowych stanów bazowych działanie jest wyznaczone przez liniowość. Warto sobie przypomnieć,
że z Boolean circuit dla f możemy zbudować circuit dla tej operacji UF przy koszcie, który jest
liniowy w rozmiarze Boolean circuit. Phase query gate dla f, z drugiej strony, który będziemy oznaczać
nazwą ZF, działa w taki sposób. W szczególności ten gate działa na
małych n qubitach w przeciwieństwie do małych n plus jeden qubitach i zasadniczo automatycznie wrzuca wartość funkcji
do fazy zamiast XOR-ować wartość wyjściową na dodatkowy qubit, jak mamy dla
UF. Więc jeśli pomyślimy o tym, co się dzieje, kiedy używamy phase kickback na gate UF,
w zasadzie tylko implementujemy ZF. Potrzebujemy stanu minus i kosztuje to jedno
obliczenie UF, ale rzeczywiście odzyskujemy stan minus i możemy go użyć dla następnego, jeśli chcemy, lub możemy
go po prostu wyrzucić. To jest właśnie phase query gate. Teraz, jeśli jesteśmy po prostu
dani phase query gate ZF i jest to jedyny sposób, w jaki mamy dostęp do funkcji f, to nie możemy
odzyskać gate UF, ale jeśli mamy kontrolowaną wersję ZF, możemy
zbudować gate UF i to pozostawię ci jako
ćwiczenie. Oprócz phase query gate dla funkcji f będziemy również potrzebować phase query gate dla n-bitowej
funkcji OR, czyli innymi słowy funkcji, która przyjmuje wartość zero, gdy jest podane ciąg samych zer, a w przeciwnym razie
przyjmuje wartość jeden. I wprost sposób, w jaki zor działa na standardowych stanach bazowych, jest pokazany
tutaj na ekranie. Ten gate nie zależy od funkcji f, więc nie wymaga
żadnych zapytań, a jednym ze sposobów budowy quantum circuit implementującego tę operację jest zrobienie czegoś
podobnego do tego, co zrobiliśmy dla funkcji f, z tym że zaczynamy od Boolean circuit obliczającego funkcję OR na
n bitach. Teraz, gdy mamy te gates, jesteśmy gotowi przejść do następnej
sekcji. Teraz omówimy algorytm Grovera, zaczynając od opisu algorytmu. Zaczynamy od inicjalizacji
małych n qubitów, każdego do stanu plus, lub innymi słowy, wprowadzamy te qubity w równą superpozycję wszystkich
binarnych ciągów o długości n. To, co zamierzamy zrobić, to skutecznie kierować stan tych qubitów
w stronę rozwiązania, więc intuicyjne jest, że zaczynamy w tym stanie, ponieważ nie wiemy jeszcze nic o funkcji f.
W tym momencie każdy ciąg jest równie prawdopodobny jako rozwiązanie i odzwierciedla to fakt, że te qubity są w równej superpozycji wszystkich
ciągów. Następnie iterujemy: wielokrotnie stosujemy operację Grovera, która jest prawdziwym sercem
algorytmu i którą opiszę za chwilę. Stosujemy tę operację łącznie T razy, gdzie T jest pewną nieujemną
liczbą całkowitą, ale ta liczba nie jest określona przez sam algorytm. Musimy jakoś wybrać T i w następnej
sekcji będziemy mówić o dobrych wyborach dla T, ale na razie możemy myśleć o tej liczbie iteracji T jako
dowolnej. I na koniec mierzymy w standardowej bazie i to daje nam
kandydata na rozwiązanie. Nie ma gwarancji, że jest to rozwiązanie, ale jeśli dobrze wybierzemy T, to
prawdopodobieństwo otrzymania rozwiązania może być duże. I oto operacja Grovera
WEBVTT
sama, którą nazwaliśmy G. Jest to złożenie operacji, wszystkich na N qubitach, więc jest to N-qubitowa
operacja. Najpierw mamy gate ZF, czyli innymi słowy phase query gate dla
funkcji wejściowej f, następnie warstwa Hadamard gates, a potem mamy zor, który jest phase query gate dla funkcji
OR, i wreszcie kolejna warstwa Hadamard gates. Widzimy więc, że jedna iteracja w
kroku drugim może być zaimplementowana przez circuit o postaci pokazanej tutaj na ekranie, i mamy tu cztery qubity przy okazji,
ale ogólnie możemy mieć dowolną liczbę qubitów. Kluczową rzeczą do zauważenia jest to, że potrzebujemy jednego zapytania o f, żeby zaimplementować G.
Potrzebujemy jednego zapytania do zaimplementowania ZF, a żadna z pozostałych operacji nie jest zależna od f, więc nie wymagają żadnych zapytań. Tak więc ta liczba T,
która reprezentuje liczbę razy, kiedy stosujemy G w kroku drugim, reprezentuje również liczbę zapytań, których
potrzebujemy. Oto typowy sposób, w jaki możemy używać algorytmu Grovera, ale z pewnością nie jest to jedyny sposób, jak mówiłem
wcześniej. Pierwszą rzeczą, którą musimy zrobić, jest wybranie T i zajmiemy się tym w następnej sekcji.
Dla wybranego T uruchamiamy algorytm Grovera przez T iteracji i otrzymujemy kandydata na rozwiązanie
x. Nie ma gwarancji, że x jest naprawdę rozwiązaniem, ale możemy wydać jedno dodatkowe zapytanie, żeby sprawdzić. Jeśli mamy rozwiązanie, możemy
wypisać to rozwiązanie i zatrzymać się, a w przeciwnym razie możemy spróbować ponownie, ewentualnie z innym wyborem T,
ale niekoniecznie, lub możemy się poddać i zgłosić, że nie ma żadnych rozwiązań. Jak mówiłem wcześniej, to nie
jest jedyny sposób użycia algorytmu, ale jest to naturalny sposób jego zastosowania do problemu wyszukiwania. Następnie zobaczymy, co operacja Grovera
rzeczywiście robi ze stanem N qubitów, na które działa. Pomyślmy o naszych n qubitach jako
tworzących jeden rejestr, który nazwiemy Q, żeby nadać mu jakąś nazwę. Pamiętaj, że to, co robimy najpierw w
algorytmie Grovera, to wprowadzamy Q w jednolitą superpozycję wszystkich n-bitowych ciągów i robimy to, stosując Hadamard
gates do n qubitów w stanie wszystkich zer. Następnie iterujemy operację Grovera G, a potem
mierzymy. Będzie pomocne podzielenie zbioru wszystkich n-bitowych ciągów na dwa zbiory A zero i
A jeden. A zero zawiera wszystkie ciągi, które powodują, że f przyjmuje wartość zero, a A jeden zawiera wszystkie ciągi, które powodują, że f
przyjmuje wartość jeden. Inny sposób powiedzenia tego jest taki, że A jeden zawiera wszystkie rozwiązania naszego problemu wyszukiwania,
a A zero zawiera wszystkie nie-rozwiązania. Będziemy szczególnie
zainteresowani dwoma stanami kwantowymi. Jeden to jednolita superpozycja wszystkich nie-rozwiązań, to jest ket A zero, a
drugi to jednolita superpozycja wszystkich rozwiązań i to jest ket A jeden. Powinienem zauważyć, że te definicje mają sens
tylko wtedy, gdy te zbiory są niepuste, ponieważ w przeciwnym razie sumujemy zero elementów i dzielimy przez zero. I jak będziemy
przeprowadzać tę analizę algorytmu Grovera, będziemy robić to założenie. Możemy bardzo łatwo ustalić, co
robi algorytm Grovera, gdy f jest albo stałą funkcją zerową, albo stałą funkcją jedynkową, traktując je jako przypadki szczególne, ale zostawię to
tobie do samodzielnego zrobienia. Nie zaskakująco, jeśli każdy ciąg jest rozwiązaniem, rzeczywiście otrzymamy
rozwiązanie podczas pomiaru, a jeśli nie ma żadnych rozwiązań, nie otrzymamy go, ponieważ w tym przypadku ich nie ma.
Ale na potrzeby tej analizy będziemy zakładać, że oba te zbiory są niepuste, żeby te
definicje tych dwóch stanów miały sens. Przy okazji, to jest dość powszechna
notacja: zawsze gdy mamy niepusty skończony zbiór s, możemy napisać ket s jako oznaczający jednolitą superpozycję elementów
tego zbioru, tak jak mamy tutaj. Zbierzmy więc te definicje w ten sposób i zobaczymy, jak łączą się
z algorytmem Grovera. Pierwszym krokiem algorytmu Grovera jest krok inicjalizacji, który wprowadza Q w jednolitą
superpozycję wszystkich n-bitowych ciągów i żeby nadać temu stanowi łatwo rozpoznawalną nazwę, nazwę go
ket u — u skrót od uniform (jednolity). Ważne dla analizy jest, żebyśmy najpierw zauważyli, że
ten jednolity stan ket u jest zawarty w podprzestrzeni rozpiętej przez dwa wektory ket A0 i ket
A1. W szczególności, jeśli weźmiemy liniową kombinację tych dwóch stanów, pokazaną tutaj na ekranie, otrzymamy ket
u. Teraz kluczem do całej analizy jest fakt, że stan Q pozostaje w
tej dwuwymiarowej podprzestrzeni bez względu na to, ile razy stosujemy operację Grovera. Wszystko sprowadzi się
więc do tego, co dzieje się w dwuwymiarowej podprzestrzeni. Zobaczmy teraz, co operacja Grovera robi, a w szczególności, co
robi z wektorami w dwuwymiarowej podprzestrzeni rozpiętej przez ket A0 i ket
A1. Pomocne jest wyobrażenie sobie, że g jest podzielone na dwie części. Jedna część to gate ZF,
a druga część to gate zor otoczony dwiema warstwami Hadamard
gates. Oto definicja ZF sprzed chwili i dość bezpośrednio z tej definicji wynika, że jego
działanie na nasze dwa stany — jednolite superpozycje nie-rozwiązań i rozwiązań — polega po prostu na wstawieniu znaku minus
przed ket A1. Nic nie dzieje się z ket A0 i to wszystko, co musimy wiedzieć
o ZF na potrzeby tej analizy. Dla drugiej części, którą jest
gate zor otoczony dwiema warstwami Hadamard gates, zacznijmy od przypomnienia, jak zdefiniowany jest zor. Jednym ze sposobów jego zapisania
jest to, co pokazano na ekranie. Jest to to samo wyrażenie, co wcześniej, a innym sposobem wyrażenia go przy użyciu notacji dyrekta
jest to, co tutaj, i możesz to wyrazenie zweryfikować, zastanawiając się, jak operacja
po prawej stronie działa na standardowych stanach bazowych. W szczególności nie robi nic ze stanem wszystkich zer i każdy
inny standardowy stan bazowy otrzymuje znak minus, co zgadza się z definicją z
or. Jeśli więc otworzymy tę operację między dwiema warstwami Hadamard gates, otrzymamy podobne wyrażenie, z tym że
zamiast standardowego stanu bazowego wszystkich zer mamy teraz naszą jednolitą superpozycję ket u, i to dlatego, że H tensor
n przekształca standardowy stan bazowy zer do ket u, a także H tensor n jest swoim własnym sprzężonym transpozitem, więc działa w
podobny sposób działając od prawej na bra zamiast na ket. Teraz ustalimy,
co G robi z naszymi dwoma wektorami A0 i A1, korzystając z faktów, które właśnie
zaobserwowaliśmy. Zacznijmy od A0. Najpierw podstawmy wyrażenie,
które uzyskaliśmy dla gate zor otoczonego dwiema warstwami Hadamard gates. Następnie możemy skorzystać z faktu, że ZF nie robi nic
WEBVTT
z ket A zero, możemy więc pozbyć się operacji ZF. Teraz korzystając z opisu
ket u, który mamy tutaj, wraz z faktem, że ket A0 i ket A1 są prostopadłymi wektorami jednostkowymi, możemy obliczyć
iloczyn tego bra tutaj i tego ket, i co otrzymujemy to pierwiastek kwadratowy z liczby nie-rozwiązań
podzielony przez n. Możemy skorzystać z tego faktu, żeby obliczyć wynik i podstawiając nasze wyrażenie dla ket u i
upraszczając, otrzymujemy ostateczny wynik pokazany tutaj na ekranie. W szczególności zauważ, że ten
wektor jest zawarty w dwuwymiarowej podprzestrzeni rozpiętej przez ket A0 i ket A1, jak sugerowałem wcześniej, i
co więcej, współczynniki okazują się być liczbami rzeczywistymi, jak zawsze zweryfikuj to
we własnym tempie, jeśli chcesz to zrobić. Mam tendencję do szybkiego przechodzenia przez takie rzeczy w tych filmach z
oczekiwaniem, że zatrzymasz film, żeby się nad tym zastanowić, jeśli chcesz to zrobić. Więc porządkujemy to, żeby
zachować ostateczny wynik na później. Teraz zrobimy coś podobnego dla wektora ket
A1. Możemy użyć tego samego wyrażenia G jak poprzednio, i tym razem gate ZF wstrzykuje
znak minus, który tutaj odzwierciedla się przez to, że zamieniliśmy dwa wyrazy w nawiasie w
operacji. Następnie postępujemy w bardzo podobny sposób i ostateczny wynik jest podobny, z tym że dwa współczynniki
są zamienione i mamy teraz znak minus przed jednym z nich, co jest po prostu sposobem, w jaki działa algebra. I ponownie możesz
to sprawdzić we własnym tempie. Zauważ, że ponownie mamy rzeczywistą liniową kombinację naszych dwóch wektorów ket A0 i
ket A1. Porządkujemy i ten i łączymy wynik końcowy z poprzednim. Teraz możemy zobaczyć, jak G
działa na podprzestrzeni rozpiętej przez nasze dwa wektory. Jednym ze sposobów jest wyrażenie tego w postaci macierzy 2x2 M, pokazanej
tutaj na ekranie. I żeby wyjaśnić, co robimy tutaj: łączymy pierwszy wiersz i pierwszą
kolumnę z ket A0, a drugi wiersz i kolumnę z ket A1. Do tej pory w serii
używaliśmy macierzy głównie do opisu sposobu działania operacji na standardowych stanach bazowych, ale jest powszechne używanie macierzy
do opisywania działań odwzorowań liniowych na różnych zestawach wektorów, nie tylko standardowych stanach bazowych, i tutaj mówimy o tym, co robi operacja G
z wektorami ket A0 i ket A1. Możemy powiedzieć więcej o tym, co G robi z wektorami w
przestrzeni rozpiętej przez ket A0 i ket A1, jeśli dokładniej przyjrzymy się tej macierzy M. W szczególności, co odkryjemy, to
że m jest macierzą obrotu, co oznacza, że jej działanie na tę dwuwymiarową przestrzeń można opisać jako obrót o pewien
stały kąt. Jest kilka różnych sposobów, żeby to zobaczyć, i jednym z nich jest zaobserwowanie,
że tę macierz M można wyrazić jako kwadrat macierzy, która wygląda nieco prościej. To może być trudne do zauważenia, jeśli
patrzymy tylko na M, ale nie musimy tego odkrywać sami, wystarczy to zweryfikować i możemy to zrobić, po prostu
podnosząc do kwadratu macierz po prawej stronie. Innym sposobem zapisania macierzy po prawej stronie, nie włączając kwadratu, jest
to, co pokazano na ekranie, i jest to typowy sposób opisywania obrotu o dany kąt Theta jako
macierzy. Dokładny kąt, o który się obracamy, to arcus sinus pierwiastka kwadratowego z liczby
rozwiązań podzielonej przez N. I przy okazji, ponieważ widzimy to po raz pierwszy, powinienem zwrócić uwagę, że
ten kąt jest bardzo ważny. Będzie pojawiać się ciągle w miarę kontynuowania tej
analizy. Argument arcus sinusa jest liczbą między 0 a 1, a konkretnie sposób, w jaki
interpretujemy tu arcus sinus, to kąt między 0 a Pi/2, który daje nam argument, gdy weźmiemy
sinus. To jeden sposób myślenia o tej macierzy, którą podnosiliśmy do kwadratu, żeby uzyskać
M. I ponieważ podnoszenie macierzy do kwadratu jest tym samym, co stosowanie jej dwa razy, widzimy, że M można alternatywnie zapisać jako
obrót nie o kąt Theta, ale o 2 * Theta, ponieważ przez podnoszenie do kwadratu obracamy o kąt Theta
dwa razy. Innym sposobem weryfikacji tego wszystkiego, w razie gdyby to pomogło, jest zacząć od tego końcowego wyrażenia M
i użyć wzorów na podwójny kąt z trygonometrii, żeby uzyskać oryginalne wyrażenie
M. I oto wyrażenie M, które opisuje działanie, jakie g ma na podprzestrzeni rozpiętej przez ket A0 i ket A1, które będzie
najbardziej przydatne w przyszłości. Wracając teraz do samego algorytmu Grovera, po
kroku inicjalizacji, ale przed jakimikolwiek zastosowaniami G, stan naszego n-qubitowego rejestru Q to ket u, czyli
jednolita superpozycja wszystkich n-bitowych ciągów. I mamy tutaj to samo wyrażenie ket u w kategoriach ket A0 i
ket A1 co poprzednio, ale teraz, gdy zidentyfikowaliśmy ten kąt Theta, widzimy, że
możemy alternatywnie zapisać ket u jako cosinus Theta razy ket A0 plus sinus Theta razy ket
A1. To jest jasne dla współczynnika ket A1, a dla drugiego współczynnika wystarczy zauważyć, że rozmiar A0 plus
rozmiar A1 wynosi N, a następnie możemy to uzyskać z podstawowej trygonometrii. To jest więc stan, od którego
zaczynamy, a za pierwszym razem, gdy stosujemy G, obracamy o kąt 2 * Theta, więc całkowity kąt staje się 3 *
Theta. A jeśli zastosujemy G ponownie, kąt wzrasta do 5 Theta, bo efektywnie obróciliśmy o dodatkowy
kąt 2 Theta. I tak dalej. Więc po T zastosowaniach G możemy przedstawić
otrzymany stan tak jak pokazano na ekranie, gdzie kąt naszego stanu wynosi 2T + 1 razy Theta, czyli 2 * Theta
dla każdego zastosowania G, plus dodatkowe Theta, ponieważ to jest stan, od którego zaczęliśmy.
Możemy też myśleć o działaniu operacji Grovera w kategoriach geometrycznych i to pomaga rzucić nieco światła na to, jak
działa i dlaczego jej efektem jest obrót stanu rejestru Q. Oto główna idea. Operacja Grovera
jest złożeniem dwóch części, które już zidentyfikowaliśmy. Jedna to ZF, a druga to zor otoczony
dwiema warstwami Hadamard gates. Te dwie części są
odbiciami, a kiedy składamy dwa odbicia, otrzymujemy obrót. Zobaczmy, jak to działa w
bardziej szczegółowy sposób. Najpierw skupmy się na ZF i ograniczymy uwagę do
tej samej dwuwymiarowej podprzestrzeni, o której mówiliśmy, czyli tej rozpiętej przez ket A0 i ket
A1. Jak już zaobserwowaliśmy, działanie ZF na tej przestrzeni jest dość proste: nie robi nic
z ket A zero i wstawia znak minus przed ket A1. To jest odbicie i konkretnie
WEBVTT
jest to odbicie względem prostej równoległej do ket A0, którą nazwiemy L1, żeby nadać jej
nazwę. Żeby zobaczyć, dlaczego jest to odbicie, pomocne jest narysowanie rysunku. Mamy tu nasze dwa wektory ket
A0 i ket A1, które są prostopadłymi wektorami jednostkowymi i możemy myśleć o ekranie jako o wszystkich rzeczywistych
kombinacjach liniowych tych dwóch wektorów. Okrąg więc reprezentuje wszystkie wektory jednostkowe, dla których współczynniki przy
tych dwóch wektorach są liczbami rzeczywistymi. Oto prosta L1, która jest równoległa do ket A0, i jeśli rozważymy pewien
dowolny wektor s na tym okręgu, to efektem zastosowania ZF jest odbicie względem tej prostej, jak pokazano na
ekranie, po prostu dlatego, że nic nie robimy z ket A zero i wstawiamy znak minus przed ket
A1. W szczególnym przypadku, gdy s jest ket A zero, na przykład, nic się nie dzieje, gdy wykonujemy to odbicie, a gdy s jest
ket A1, odbicie przenosi nas aż do ujemnego ket A1, i to jest zgodne z działaniem ZF. Więc ZF jest
odbiciem, które można zwizualizować tak jak mamy tutaj. Drugą częścią G, którą jest zor
otoczony dwiema warstwami Hadamard gates, można wyrazić jako 2 razy ket bra u minus macierz jednostkowa, jak już
widzieliśmy, i ponownie jest to odbicie, tym razem względem prostej L2 równoległej do ket u, a nie ket
A0. Możemy zwizualizować tę operację w podobny sposób do ZF. Oto wektor ket
u, a więc to jest prosta L2 równoległa do ket u, i ponownie działanie na dowolny wektor s polega na odbiciu
względem prostej, którą w tym przypadku jest L2.
I na koniec, jak wspomniałem wcześniej, zawsze gdy składamy dwa odbicia, otrzymujemy obrót, a konkretnie
obrót o dwukrotność kąta między prostymi odbicia. Narysujmy więc podobny
rysunek do poprzedniego. Mamy tutaj proste odbicia, między którymi jest kąt Theta,
i jeśli weźmiemy dowolny wektor s, odbimy go względem pierwszej prostej L1,
a następnie odbijem względem drugiej prostej L2, to efektem netto będzie obrót wektora s o kąt dwukrotnie Theta.
I to jest prawda w ogólności, i możesz to wypróbować na kilku dodatkowych przykładach samodzielnie, żeby zobaczyć, że rzeczywiście tak to
działa. Tak czy owak, mam nadzieję, że to pomaga ci intuicyjnie zrozumieć, dlaczego operacja Grovera ma efekt obracania
wektorów. Następnie przejdziemy do kwestii wyboru liczby iteracji T w algorytmie Grovera.
Zacznijmy od zastanowienia się, jak analiza, którą do tej pory widzieliśmy, ujawniając, co robi operacja Grovera
gdy stosujemy ją wielokrotnie do jednolitej superpozycji, odnosi się do zadania, które chcemy rozwiązać, czyli znalezienia rozwiązania naszego problemu wyszukiwania
lub innymi słowy dowolnego ciągu zawartego w zbiorze A1. Krótko mówiąc, zasadniczo ustalimy
cel, a następnie określimy, ile razy stosować operację Grovera, żeby się do niego zbliżyć.
Najpierw wyobraźmy sobie, że mamy dowolny stan będący liniową kombinacją naszych dwóch wektorów ket A0 i ket
A1. Jeśli wykonamy pomiar w standardowej bazie na tym stanie, to wynik z zestawu A1, który jest
zestawem rozwiązań naszego problemu wyszukiwania, uzyskamy z prawdopodobieństwem równym wartości bezwzględnej podniesionej do kwadratu współczynnika, który mamy dla ket A1. I dla
wektora pokazanego na ekranie ten współczynnik to beta. To jest intuicyjne: gdybyśmy zmierzyli stan ket A0,
otrzymalibyśmy losowe nie-rozwiązanie, a gdybyśmy zmierzyli ket A1, otrzymalibyśmy losowe rozwiązanie. Więc jeśli zmierzymy ten stan
tutaj, to uzyskamy losowe nie-rozwiązanie z prawdopodobieństwem wartości bezwzględnej Alfa do kwadratu i losowe rozwiązanie
z prawdopodobieństwem wartości bezwzględnej beta do kwadratu. Ale możemy też po prostu chwilę to przepracować. Oto stan zapisany
tak, żebyśmy mogli zobaczyć wpisy tego wektora dla standardowych stanów bazowych. Jeśli więc zmierzymy, to są
prawdopodobieństwa uzyskania każdego możliwego wyniku, a żeby uzyskać prawdopodobieństwo znalezienia rozwiązania, sumujemy
prawdopodobieństwa dla wszystkich możliwych rozwiązań, co daje nam wartość bezwzględną beta do kwadratu, jak
oczekiwano. Teraz przeanalizowaliśmy już, co się dzieje, gdy uruchamiamy algorytm Grovera przez T iteracji — otrzymujemy stan pokazany
tutaj na ekranie. Ponieważ współczynnik ket A1 to sinus
(2T + 1) * Theta, gdzie ponownie jest ten bardzo ważny kąt Theta,
to zobaczymy rozwiązanie z prawdopodobieństwem sin² z (2T + 1) *
Theta. Chcielibyśmy, żeby to prawdopodobieństwo było duże, najlepiej jak najbliższe jeden. Tak więc, gdy obracamy wektor stanu
przez iterowanie G, będziemy myśleć o ket A1 jako o stanie docelowym i będziemy starać się
wybrać T tak, żeby wylądować blisko tego stanu. I robiąc to, dobrze mieć na uwadze, że chcielibyśmy również
zminimalizować T, ponieważ to jest liczba zapytań, które musimy wykonać. Jeśli więc chcemy, żeby to
prawdopodobieństwo było bliskie jeden i zminimalizować T, sensowne jest próba, żeby kąt naszego wektora stanu był bliski Pi/2, ponieważ
jest to najmniejszy kąt, który sprawia, że kwadrat sinusa jest duży. Więc w zasadzie jest to nasza pierwsza możliwość uczynienia prawdopodobieństwa dużym, gdy obracamy
wektor stanu. Nie zawsze możemy dokładnie trafić w ten kąt Pi/2, ponieważ T musi
być liczbą całkowitą, ale jeśli myślimy o tym w przybliżeniu i rozwiążemy dla T, jakby to była nierówność, to widzimy, że idealnie
wybranie T równego Pi przez 4 razy Theta minus 1/2 ma
sens. Ale oczywiście T musi być nieujemną liczbą całkowitą, więc zrobimy
to: weźmiemy najbliższą liczbę całkowitą do tego, co wyobrażamy sobie jako idealną wartość, którą jest podłoga z Pi podzielonego przez 4 razy
Theta. Przyjmowanie podłogi oznacza nawiasem mówiąc, że wyrzucamy część ułamkową, czyli innymi słowy jest to największa
liczba całkowita mniejsza lub równa temu, z czego bierzemy podłogę. Zgodnie z tym wyrażeniem, jeśli
idealna wartość przypada dokładnie w połowie między liczbami całkowitymi, zaokrąglimy w górę, ale to nie będzie w ogóle mieć znaczenia dla
celów tej lekcji. Tak więc będziemy skupiać się na tym konkretnym wyborze
T. Ale jest jeszcze jedna ważna kwestia, którą musimy wziąć pod uwagę: ta specyfikacja T zależy
od tego, ile jest rozwiązań, ponieważ kąt Theta zależy od liczby
rozwiązań. Od tej chwili będę używać litery s do oznaczania liczby rozwiązań, czyli innymi słowy rozmiaru
zbioru A jeden, dla wygody. W każdym razie chodzi o to, że nasze
wyrażenie dla T — wartość, którą hipotetycznie powinna być dobra — zależy od Theta, a Theta zależy od s, czyli
WEBVTT
rozmiaru zbioru A1. Nie jest to problemem, jeśli z góry wiemy, ile jest rozwiązań, ale
jeśli nie wiemy z góry, ile jest rozwiązań, nie wiemy, czym jest Theta, więc nie możemy wybrać T w ten sposób
i będziemy musieli zrobić coś innego. Wrócę do sytuacji, gdy nie znamy s trochę później, ale na
razie skupmy się na sytuacji, w której wiemy, ile jest rozwiązań, zaczynając od unikalnego wyszukiwania,
gdzie jest zagwarantowane jedno unikalne rozwiązanie, którego szukamy.
Wspomniałem o unikalnym problemie wyszukiwania jako przykładzie problemu zapytań z powrotem w lekcji
piątej. Wejściem jest funkcja f z n bitów na jeden bit, istnieje unikalny n-bitowy
ciąg, który powoduje, że f przyjmuje wartość jeden i celem jest wypisanie tego ciągu. Więc
jest to równoważne nieustrukturyzowanemu problemowi wyszukiwania, o którym mówiliśmy, ale z obietnicą, że jest dokładnie jedno rozwiązanie. I rzeczywiście, jest to
jedyna wersja problemu wyszukiwania, którą Lov Grover rozważał w swoim oryginalnym artykule z 1996 roku, który wprowadził algorytm Grovera.
Dla unikalnego wyszukiwania mamy s równe 1, a zatem ten ważny kąt Theta jest równy arcuś sinusowi
z pierwiastka z 1/n. Gdy N jest duże, ta wartość jest w przybliżeniu równa pierwiastkowi z 1/N, i
to dlatego, że dla coraz mniejszych kątów funkcja sinusa zaczyna wyglądać coraz bardziej jak funkcja identyczności.
Jeśli podstawimy to przybliżenie do naszego wyboru T, to widzimy, że T jest w przybliżeniu równe podłodze
z Pi/4 razy pierwiastek z N. To dobrze, bo jesteśmy na dobrej drodze do używania O pierwiastka z N
zapytań, chociaż w tym momencie nie sprawdziliśmy jeszcze dokładnie, jak dobrze działa algorytm.
Przyjrzyjmy się przykładowi, gdzie duże N wynosi 128, czyli 2 do 7, więc
nasza funkcja f jest z siedmiu bitów na jeden bit i zakładamy, że istnieje unikalne rozwiązanie. Ale żeby ustalić, jak
dobrze działa algorytm, musimy skupić się tylko na kącie Theta, który możemy obliczyć.
Wynosi on w przybliżeniu 0,0885 radiana, co jest nieco ponad 5° i jeśli podstawimy tę wartość do naszego
wyrażenia dla T, to otrzymujemy osiem. Więc myślimy o tym, co się dzieje, gdy szukamy unikalnego rozwiązania spośród 128
możliwości używając ośmiu zapytań. Możemy narysować rysunek ilustrujący, jak stan zmienia się w czasie
gdy wykonujemy iteracje operacji Grovera. Jak poprzednio, mamy stany ket
A0 i ket A1 i w tym konkretnym przypadku, czyli unikalnym wyszukiwaniu, mamy, że ket A1 jest w rzeczywistości standardowym stanem bazowym
odpowiadającym unikalnemu rozwiązaniu, cokolwiek to jest. Cóż, ket A0 to jednolita superpozycja wszystkich
ciągów oprócz unikalnego rozwiązania. Oto jednolita superpozycja wszystkich ciągów, którą
możemy zapisać jako cosinus Theta razy ket A0 plus sinus Theta razy ket A1. Ma sens, że ket A0
i ket u są bliskie w tym przypadku, bo jak zauważyliśmy przed chwilą, ket A0 jest
prawie jednolitą superpozycją wszystkich ciągów — brakuje tylko jednego ciągu, czyli unikalnego rozwiązania. Stosując G ponownie, obracamy o
dodatkowe 2 Theta, więc tu jesteśmy po dwóch iteracjach. Oto trzy, cztery, pięć, sześć, siedem i osiem
i teraz widzimy, że jesteśmy dość blisko ket A1. Więc jeśli zatrzymamy się i zmierzymy w tym momencie, bardzo prawdopodobnie uzyskamy
unikalne rozwiązanie. I rzeczywiście, w tym przypadku jest tylko około pół procenta szans, że nie uzyskamy unikalnego
rozwiązania. Z drugiej strony, gdybyśmy kontynuowali stosowanie operacji Grovera więcej niż zalecane osiem razy,
to prawdopodobieństwo uzyskania rozwiązania zmalałoby i z czasem oscylowałoby, gdy stan okrążałby
okrąg. Ważne jest więc, żebyśmy zatrzymali iteracje w odpowiednim czasie, jeśli chcemy odnieść sukces z dużym
prawdopodobieństwem. Pomyślmy o prawdopodobieństwie, że nasz wybór T ujawni unikalne rozwiązanie bardziej ogólnie, dla różnych wartości
N. Zapiszemy p(N,1), żeby oznaczać prawdopodobieństwo, że algorytm Grovera znajdzie unikalne rozwiązanie z powodzeniem
dla każdej możliwej wartości N. Jedynka oznacza jedno rozwiązanie i rozszerzymy tę notację na inne liczby rozwiązań
wkrótce. Oto tabela tych prawdopodobieństw dla małych potęg dwójki. Zaczyna się od N=2 i
prawdopodobieństwo wynosi 1/2, co nie jest zbyt dobre, ale dla N=4 prawdopodobieństwo wynosi dokładnie jeden, więc działa
idealnie w tym przypadku. To świetne ćwiczenie nawiasem mówiąc — jawnie przejść przez te dwa przypadki,
szczególnie przypadek gdy N wynosi cztery. W tym przypadku szukamy jednego rozwiązania spośród czterech możliwości,
potrzebujemy tylko jednego zapytania i działa to idealnie. Gdy N rośnie, widzimy pewne fluktuacje, prawdopodobieństwa idą
trochę w górę i w dół, ale wydają się zbliżać do jedynki i rzeczywiście tak jest. Można to udowodnić
analitycznie, że prawdopodobieństwo jest zawsze co najmniej 1 - 1/N. Więc to dobrze:
algorytm nie jest doskonały, nie mamy gwarancji uzyskania rozwiązania, ale jest całkiem prawdopodobny, szczególnie dla dużych
wartości N, a także bardzo ciekawa anomalia, która pojawia się gdy N wynosi 4.
Powinienem też zauważyć, że zawsze możemy uruchomić cały algorytm, łącznie z pomiarami, dowolną liczbę razy, i jeśli jeden z nich
się powiedzie, uzyskamy rozwiązanie. Więc jeśli te prawdopodobieństwa nie są wystarczająco dobre, możemy łatwo je zwiększyć, po prostu uruchamiając
algorytm ponownie. W rzeczywistości nawet gdyby te prawdopodobieństwa wynosiły wszystkie 1/2 na przykład, nadal mielibyśmy
użyteczny algorytm wyszukiwania. Rozważmy teraz, co dzieje się, gdy istnieje wiele
rozwiązań. Zacznijmy od podobnego przykładu do poprzedniego. Ponownie N wynosi 128, ale tym razem
liczba rozwiązań s wynosi cztery zamiast 1. Ponownie możemy obliczyć Theta i T i
dostajemy, że Theta wynosi około 0,1777 lub trochę ponad 10°, a T wynosi
cztery tym razem. Więc kąt jest około dwa razy większy od wartości z poprzedniego przykładu, a T jest połową tego, czym
był. Możemy narysować rysunek jak poprzednio. Oto gdzie
zaczynamy. Oto jedna iteracja, dwie, trzy i cztery. Tym razem jesteśmy bardzo blisko ket
A1 i prawdopodobieństwo znalezienia rozwiązania tym razem okazuje się być większe niż
99,9%. Ale gdybyśmy nie wiedzieli lepiej i myśleli, że istnieje tylko jedno rozwiązanie, wzięlibyśmy T równe 8 jak
poprzednio, obrócilibyśmy prawie przez całą drogę do ujemnego ket A0 i prowadziłoby to do bardzo małego prawdopodobieństwa
sukcesu. Więc to kolejny przykład pokazujący, że są dobre wybory T i złe wybory T, i tutaj widzimy,
WEBVTT
że dobry wybór dla s równego 1 okazuje się być bardzo złym wyborem dla s równego 4. Ale zakładając, że znamy s z
góry i wybieramy T zgodnie z naszą specyfikacją, okazuje się, że algorytm Grovera znajdzie rozwiązanie
z prawdopodobieństwem co najmniej 1 minus s przez N, a często będzie znacznie większe niż to. Jest to też co najmniej s przez N, ale
to jest naprawdę znacznie mniej interesujące. Co jest bardziej interesujące, to że gdy ułamek s przez N staje się mały, dolne oszacowanie
prawdopodobieństwa sukcesu zbliża się coraz bardziej do jedynki. Teraz, jak już kilkakrotnie zauważałem,
liczba T reprezentuje nie tylko liczbę iteracji operacji Grovera, które wykonujemy, ale też liczbę
zapytań, które wykonujemy. Więc jak ta liczba zależy od s i
N? Zacznijmy najpierw od faktu, że arcus sinus z x jest zawsze co najmniej x, pod warunkiem że x jest między zerem a 1.
Jest to dość łatwe do pokazania, jeśli znasz szereg Taylora dla funkcji arcus sinusa, ale są też inne sposoby to uzasadnić, i po prostu
przyjmujemy to za dane, bo to jest prawda. Oznacza to, że Theta jest co najmniej pierwiastkiem z s/
N, a co za tym idzie T jest co najwyżej Pi/4 razy pierwiastek z N/
s. Więc to jest jeszcze lepsze niż O pierwiastka z N. Im większe s jest
w porównaniu z N, tym mniej zapytań musimy wykonać i w pewnym sensie nie jest zaskakujące, że ten ułamek pojawia się
w ten sposób, biorąc pod uwagę, że jego odwrotność definiuje Theta, a ostatecznie Theta jest tym, co naprawdę ma znaczenie dla
tej analizy. Jak właśnie widzieliśmy, algorytm Grovera działa całkiem dobrze, gdy znamy z góry
ile jest rozwiązań. Ale co, jeśli nie znamy, ile jest rozwiązań?
Jest jedno dość proste podejście, polegające na losowym wyborze liczby iteracji,
a konkretnie wybieranie T jednolicie losowo między 1 a podłogą z Pi/4 razy pierwiastek z N okazuje się
być całkiem dobrym sposobem na to. Górna granica tego zakresu jest mniej więcej liczbą zapytań, które wybralibyśmy dla unikalnego wyszukiwania i właściwie
jest to dokładna właściwa liczba w większości przypadków. Jest to sytuacja gdy kąt Theta jest tak mały, jak tylko może być, z wyłączeniem
trywialnego przypadku, gdy nie ma żadnych rozwiązań. Pomysł jest taki, że zamiast starannie celować naszym wektorem stanu w
ket A1, jak robiliśmy, gdy wiedzieliśmy ile jest rozwiązań, zasadniczo obracamy o losowy kąt, jakbyśmy dawali
wektorowi stanu losowy obrót. Jeśli zdarzy się, że jest tylko jedno rozwiązanie, to nasz losowy obrót może popchnąć
wektor stanu blisko ket A1, ale może też po prostu zaledwie go przybliżyć. A jeśli zdarzy się, że jest wiele rozwiązań, to
nasz losowy obrót potencjalnie może wysłać wektor stanu wielokrotnie dookoła okręgu, więc nie oczekujemy, że to ujawni
rozwiązanie z prawdopodobieństwem bliskim jeden, ale szansa, że to doprowadzi do rozwiązania, jeśli ono istnieje, okazuje się być
całkiem dobra. Jest zawsze co najmniej 40%. I to nie jest oczywiste, ale tak właśnie
jest. Z pewnością nie jest to szokujące, bo prawdziwie losowy kąt miałby 50% szans na znalezienie
rozwiązania. Tak czy owak, 40% nie jest złe i pamiętaj, że zawsze możemy zwiększyć prawdopodobieństwo znalezienia rozwiązania,
powtarzając ten proces, wybierając T niezależnie za każdym razem. Robiąc to, szanse na nie
znalezienie rozwiązania, gdy ono istnieje, maleją wykładniczo wraz z liczbą powtórzeń. Więc jeśli chcemy 99-procentowej
szansy na znalezienie rozwiązania, możemy uruchomić to proste podejście 10 razy, ponownie z T wybranym niezależnie za każdym
razem. Naturalnie jeśli nie znajdziemy rozwiązania, wypisujemy brak rozwiązań. Jeśli nie ma żadnych rozwiązań,
nie znajdziemy żadnego i w takim przypadku zawsze wypisujemy prawidłową odpowiedź, czyli brak rozwiązań. Jeśli są rozwiązania,
możemy nie zdołać znaleźć żadnego i błędnie stwierdzić, że nie ma rozwiązań, ale prawdopodobieństwo tego można uczynić bardzo małym.
Mamy też, jak wspomniałem przed chwilą, że wymaga to liczby zapytań lub obliczeń f rzędu O pierwiastka z
N. Więc używając algorytmu Grovera możemy nadal rozwiązać problem wyszukiwania z dużym prawdopodobieństwem za pomocą O pierwiastka z N
zapytań, nawet jeśli nie wiemy z góry, ile jest rozwiązań. Istnieje też bardziej wyrafinowane
podejście, które może prowadzić do redukcji liczby zapytań w miarę wzrostu liczby rozwiązań. Nie będę go opisywać
szczegółowo, skupię się zamiast tego tylko na głównym pomyśle. Zaczynamy od T równego
jeden. Następnie uruchamiamy algorytm Grovera przez losową liczbę iteracji, ale gdzie górna granica to T. Więc za pierwszym razem
gdy przechodzimy do kroku drugiego, uruchomimy algorytm Grovera z jedną iteracją, ale T będzie
rosło. Jeśli znajdziemy rozwiązanie, wypisujemy je i zatrzymujemy się. A jeśli nie znajdziemy rozwiązania, robimy T
większym i próbujemy ponownie. W pewnym momencie, zanim T stanie się zbyt duże, zakończymy ten proces i
ogłosimy, że nie ma żadnych rozwiązań. To jest ta sama podstawowa idea, co w prostym podejściu, gdzie
zasadniczo dajemy wektorowi stanu losowe obroty, ale tutaj zaczynamy od lżejszych obrotów, gdy T jest
małe, na wypadek gdyby było wiele rozwiązań. W ten sposób nie marnujemy zapytań, sprawiając, że stan okrąża
i okrąża okrąg przez zbyt mocny obrót. Ale jeśli to nie działa, czyli nie znajdziemy rozwiązania, próbujemy ponownie,
ale obracamy nieco mocniej, lub potencjalnie nieco mocniej. Żeby to zadziałało, tempo
wzrostu T musi być starannie dobrane i jednym ze sposobów, żeby to zadziałało, jest zastąpienie T sufitem z 5/4 razy T.
T rośnie więc wykładniczo i intuicyjnie możemy myśleć o tym jako o obracaniu 25% mocniej za każdym
razem. I ważne jest dla analizy, że T rośnie wykładniczo w ten sposób. Czemu akurat 5/4, możesz zapytać? Cóż, to
po prostu liczba, która działa, i w rzeczywistości jest zakres wartości, które działają, ale dwa nie działa, na przykład podwajanie T
za każdym razem jest zbyt szybkim wzrostem, żeby w pełni korzystać z zalet lżejszych obrotów. Tak czy owak, celem tej bardziej
wyrafinowanej metody jest uzyskanie tego samego asymptotycznego ograniczenia liczby zapytań, co mieliśmy poprzednio:
O pierwiastka z N/s, ale nie musimy z góry wiedzieć, ile jest rozwiązań. I przy okazji,
możemy zatrzymać ten proces, gdy T osiągnie pierwiastek z N. Jeśli więc nie ma żadnych rozwiązań, dojdziemy do tego wniosku po O
pierwiastka z N zapytań. I tak właśnie możemy wybrać liczbę iteracji w algorytmie Grovera. Na zakończenie lekcji
zrobię tylko kilka krótkich uwag o algorytmie Grovera. Po pierwsze, w modelu zapytań
algorytm Grovera jest asymptotycznie optymalny. Oznacza to, że nie jest możliwe wymyślenie
algorytmu zapytań do rozwiązania problemu wyszukiwania, a nawet konkretnie unikalnego problemu wyszukiwania, który używa asymptotycznie
WEBVTT
mniej niż O pierwiastka z N zapytań w najgorszym przypadku. To jest coś, co można udowodnić rygorystycznie
i rzeczywiście istnieje wiele znanych dowodów tego faktu. Co ciekawe, było to wiadome nawet
przed odkryciem algorytmu Grovera. Algorytm Grovera pasował do już wtedy znanych dolnych oszacowań liczby
zapytań. Od czasu do czasu ludzie wymyślają podejścia, o których uważają, że są asymptotycznie
lepsze od algorytmu Grovera, ale zawsze jest albo błąd, albo założenie dotyczące funkcji f i
sposobu dostępu do niej, lub jakiś inny problematyczny problem, który sprawia, że twierdzenie jest nieprawidłowe. Jeśli pracujesz poprawnie
w modelu zapytań, nie możesz pobić algorytmu Grovera dla nieustrukturyzowanego wyszukiwania. Po drugie, algorytm Grovera jest
dość szeroko stosowany w tym sensie, że przyspieszenie pierwiastkowe, które algorytm Grovera oferuje dla nieustrukturyzowanego problemu wyszukiwania, może być
uzyskane w różnych ustawieniach. Na przykład, czasami można użyć algorytmu Grovera na
szczycie innego algorytmu, żeby uzyskać kwadratową poprawę ponad wydajność tego algorytmu. Algorytm Grovera jest też
dość często używany jako podprogram wewnątrz innych algorytmów kwantowych. Jako jeden prosty przykład,
możemy użyć algorytmu Grovera, żeby uzyskać kwadratową przewagę nad klasycznymi algorytmami dla problemu minimum, o którym wspomniałem w
lekcji piątej. I wreszcie, technika używana w algorytmie Grovera, gdzie mamy dwa
odbicia, które są składane i iterowane, żeby obrócić kwantowy wektor stanu, może być uogólniona w dość
poważny sposób. Przykładem jest technika znana jako amplifikacja amplitudy, gdzie proces
uogólniający algorytm Grovera może być zastosowany do innego algorytmu kwantowego, żeby zasadniczo zwiększyć jego prawdopodobieństwo sukcesu kwadratowo szybciej niż
byłoby możliwe klasycznie. I ta technika ma szerokie zastosowania w algorytmach kwantowych. Więc może być prawdą, że
algorytm Grovera nie doprowadzi do praktycznej przewagi kwantowej prędko, jeśli w ogóle, ale algorytm Grovera jest
bez wątpienia fundamentalnie ważnym i szeroko stosowanym algorytmem kwantowym i jest reprezentatywny dla bardziej ogólnej techniki, która ma wiele
zastosowań. I to tyle z tej lekcji i z tej jednostki serii, która dotyczyła algorytmów kwantowych.
Omówiliśmy model zapytań i jak możemy go połączyć z bardziej standardowym modelem obliczeń, wraz z
kilkoma innymi podstawowymi pojęciami dotyczącymi sposobów mierzenia kosztu obliczeniowego. Następnie omówiliśmy estymację fazy,
faktoryzację i wreszcie algorytm Grovera. Jak już sugerowałem,
jest dużo więcej do nauczenia się o algorytmach kwantowych, ale w tej serii przejdziemy do innego tematu w następnej jednostce. W szczególności przyjrzymy się
ogólnej formalizacji informacji kwantowej, gdzie stany kwantowe są reprezentowane przez macierze pewnego
rodzaju znane jako macierze gęstości. Jak zobaczymy, ta formalizacja okazuje się być bardzo przydatna i rzeczywiście
niezbędna do zrozumienia pewnych aspektów informacji kwantowej, a także okazuje się być dość piękna z
matematycznego punktu widzenia. Mam więc nadzieję, że dołączysz do mnie w jednostce trzeciej i do zobaczenia
wkrótce.